the question is about macros while
bulking and specifically with
carbohydrate over feeding
now we have covered
protein over feeding previously on the
podcast and we've addressed the um
there's a bit of an argument going
related to protein overfeeding about
uh how likely or even possible it is for
one to gain fat with high protein over
feeding
and uh in that segment we kind of went
through it and said well thermodynamics
still work uh we can go and calculate
exactly where the energy is going there
are no free calories in this situation
but there are major impacts on
the thermic effect of feeding major
impacts on satiety and the more
controlled you get with those protein
over feeding studies the less ambiguity
is you the the more tightly controlled
those studies are the more you can
identify exactly where the consumed
calories went now with carbohydrate over
feeding
there are
two kind of common claims that get
tossed around
one is
the fact that directly converting excess
carbohydrate to fat
so that that's called de novo
lipogenesis taking extra carbohydrate
converting it directly to fat for
storage uh
a common claim you hear is that that is
very inefficient and that it rarely
occurs or almost never occurs and so
people hear those two things uh without
any context or nuance connected to them
and they start to get this idea like
okay well
if i'm not going to
you know turn this into fat and store it
perhaps there's a little bit of a cheat
code when it comes to bulking which is
just i mean as long as you're going over
with carbs whatever you're not going to
store it as fat you'll burn it all off
no big deal so you know eat the carbs to
your heart's content
and what's really important is that the
term inefficient i think needs to be
operationally defined to provide a
better understanding of what that means
and even the term rarely occurs i think
it's very important and helpful to
contextualize that with a little bit of
nuance
so
i've seen the studies that a lot of
people use when they say hey de novo
lipogenesis is super rare so rare that
it's basically not even worth
considering in any context
and when you look at those studies you
will find that they are doing
very aggressive very high carb
overfeeding but they are not doing
radical fat restriction and so usually
what happens there
is
there it's certainly a high intake of
carbohydrate but there's still plenty of
fat being consumed there so
de novo lipogenesis rarely occurs in
that context because
that's not the path of least resistance
your body is not going to see all this
influx of carbohydrate and fat it is not
going to oxidize that fat and then take
the carbohydrate and convert it to fat
for sto for storage that simply doesn't
make sense energetically um and what you
find is your body when there's this huge
influx of extra calories and it's
carbohydrate and fat
what your body likes to do is it'll
allocate some of that carbohydrate to
glycogen you know for sure
uh a lot of that fat is going to go
straight to storage and instead of
burning fat at rest which is kind of our
typical default state in a fasted
situation your body's going to say well
there's all this carbohydrate
storing it as fat is going to be a pain
in the ass let's just oxidize that
instead of the fat so like i said normal
fasting situation you're burning mostly
fat at rest
when you have this huge influx of
carbohydrate your body just says well
i'll burn the carbohydrate for energy
now
some of the carbohydrates gonna go to
glycogen the fat i'm gonna store that uh
and that's pretty much what happens and
and if the overfeeding is
large enough uh and the excess energy
intake is high enough and it's super
high carbohydrate one of the things that
you'll notice is that
carbohydrate tends to have a higher
thermic effect of feeding than fat
and so when you're trying to figure out
with this huge influx of carbohydrate if
it's not getting converted to fat and
stored where is it going
you can start to piece together exactly
where it's going
you can you can see that it's being used
mostly to it's just being oxidized to
meet energy needs at that time
some of it's going to glycogen and
you know because there is a pretty
substantial therm it's not as high as
protein but carbohydrate does have a
noteworthy thermic effect there are some
extra calories that are just getting
burned due to the thermic effect of
feeding
um and so
once there are some studies looking at
a very different scenario which is
basically what happens with
super high carb overfeeding
with
very extreme fat restriction
and when you look at that research uh
things look a little bit different of
course there's still the the high
thermic effect
or
moderate i would say thermic effect of
carbohydrate ingestion
there's no fat coming in within these
extreme experimental scenarios so
it's not going to be
you know kind of storing the fat
oxidizing the carbs what's going to
happen is with this really high carb
extremely extremely extremely low fat
over feeding
of course you know the body's going to
have that thermic effect of the meal the
body is going to oxidize carbohydrate to
meet immediate energy needs much of that
carbohydrate is going to go to saturate
glycogen stores and in some cases even
super compensate and kind of
really really pack in as much glycogen
as possible but after that
there will be some de novo lipogenesis
that occurs that absolutely has been
observed in the research and so the
question about you know is it possible
what are the situations where it might
be observed it really comes down to how
extreme is the overfeeding and how
extreme is the degree of fat restriction
so we have
everything we need in our body to do de
novo lipogenesis with carbohydrate it's
rarely the path of least resistance it's
rarely the path that makes sense because
there's usually fat coming into the diet
and we're just like whatever store the
fat burn the carbs
but i think because people often talk
about this concept without some of the
nuance and some of the details of the
studies some people have kind of gotten
the impression you know well just go
crazy with the carbs worst case scenario
you burn it all off uh but you certainly
won't store it as fat that's not
necessarily strictly the case but
practically speaking
uh you know you think of
i'm just trying to put this into real
world terms here let's say you're doing
a diet
overfeeding you're bulking hard it's a
thousand carbs a day
40 grams of fat a day 180 protein
that is
a pretty extreme macro breakdown i mean
that is only a 7 fat diet which i
personally wouldn't recommend but uh you
know it's going to be hard to get a
thousand grams of carbs and 180 grams of
protein without at least 40 grams of fat
finding their way in there you'd have to
go really far out of your way to make
that work
so even in that context you're still
getting that 40 grams of fat coming in
that could be stored
and so if you're storing 40 grams of fat
a day
and you're doing that as your kind of
daily diet even with that alone without
any need for de novo lipogenesis you're
talking about over 32 pounds of fat
stored per year
so
what happens is we kind of look at these
isolated findings that are in different
situations with different degrees of
overfeeding different degrees of fat
restriction we start making conclusions
about whether or not de novo lipogenesis
is likely to occur whether or not it's
observed commonly and then that kind of
snowballs into this kind of series of
working conclusions about
what happens with high carb over feeding
so i just wanted to kind of
explain in a little more detail what the
situation is with high carb overfeeding
because it's definitely not a cheat code
there's no free calories happening here
with with high carb over feeding but
what you will find is like i said
there's a major shift in substrate
oxidation that's for sure
uh
in most diets even with some pretty ex
pretty low fat diets like i said the
example i gave was seven percent fat you
might not even need to do much de novo
lipogenesis at all there because there
is fat that's going to be stored there
so i wanted to clarify where some of
these carbs are going and if you need to
you absolutely can do de novo
lipogenesis and convert carbohydrate to
fat that is a relatively costly way to
store carbohydrate so you will use atp
in the process and so you will see that
the energy waste that occurs there is
elevated and so
what that means is when you look at
studies that compare head to head high
carb overfeeding versus high fat over
feeding
if the calorie content of the two
overfeeding diets is equivalent you will
store more fat on the high fat over
feeding
and the reason is generally speaking
you're going to see a lower thermic
effect of feeding and metabolic pathways
for fat storage that are less costly in
that scenario so uh people will look at
these two
at interventions and say wow the high
carb over feeding led to less fat gain
than the high fat over feeding even
though calories controlled what's going
on with the missing carbs or the missing
calories from carbs it's just slightly
more costly or slightly less efficient
metabolic pathways that is leading to
some wastage just some some burning of
energy that is then because it's being
burnt not available for storage